Allrecipes member Janice shares her recipe for iced coffee,...
...saying it makes for a cooling pick-me-up of a coffee chocolate milkshake.
Start by pouring half a cup of warm water into a small bowl.
Add in two teaspoons of instant coffee granules and stir until the granules have dissolved.
Pour the coffee into your blender.
Add in one tray of ice cubes,...
...together with a half cup of milk,...
...two and a half ounces of sweetened condensed milk,...
...and one tablespoon of chocolate syrup.
Blend this mixture until smooth.
Pour it into a glass and serve immediately.
Garnish the iced coffee with whipped cream and chocolate shavings if desired.
Allrecipes member Lisa comments:
"This is the best iced coffee I have ever had.
I served this at a dinner party and everybody raved about it.
No other recipe even compares."